hi I'm Matt Welch for recent TV i'm here
in sweltering charlotte north carolina
day 0 of the Democratic National
Convention there are three stories that
we're going to be following pretty
closely here this coming week story
number one what record is Barack Obama
going to be running on not only has the
economy consistently undershot the
administration's projections and is
quite terrible and has been for a long
time but a whole series of issues the
Democrats held dear back in two thousand
eight when they tried to unseat george w
bush from closing guantanamo bay to not
prosecuting the war on drugs so terribly
to executive power writ large are just
as bad if not worse under president
obama story number two is the media
going to use the same energy
fact-checking the Democrats as they did
back checking Paul Ryan and the
Republicans we saw a kind of gloves off
moment during Ryan's speech when the
mainstream media jumped all over calling
it one of the most backed challenge and
untrustworthy untruthful speeches in
modern history well are they going to
use the same kind of diligence when
people that are more from their own side
are going to be talking we're going to
be following that story closely story
number three just what do President
Obama and Vice President Joe Biden plan
to do with the second term you haven't
seen people talk about this much there
is a vague wave of oh maybe they're
going to scale back the drug war that is
not believable for a second there's talk
very loose very unconvincing about
immigration reform there hasn't actually
been a lot of forward-looking discussion
about what policies the president might
enact instead what we're going to see
here this week is at least two former
colleagues of Mitt Romney who worked
with him at bain capital and a lot of
references to swiss bank accounts and
the like for recent TV three reasons to
watch this Democratic National
Convention I'm Matt Welch
you